chi di voi non si è mai fermato ad
osservare un cielo stellato
io ogni volta che sono di fronte a
questa immagine provo la tentazione
irresistibile di contare le stelle la su
questa un'immagine straordinaria
scattata dal telescopio hubble
l'otto dicembre del 2014 di un angolo
della via lattea 25 mila anni luce dalla
terra animali e bellissima che nasconde
una complessità straordinaria se provate
a contare le celle le stelle del nostro
cielo in ogni angolo che si riesce ad
osservare probabilmente arrivereste
accontare tra i 200 ei 400 miliardi di
stelle una quantità enorme di oggetti
che tra loro molto diversi interconnessi
che esprimono un grandissimo mistero
ancora in grande parte da esplorare ma
la cosa più straordinaria è che nel fare
quel calcolo avete messo in moto un
oggetto mille volte più complesso del
nostro della nostra galassia e il vostro
cervello
questa è l'immagine di un neurone ognuno
di noi né a 86 miliardi nel cervello
insieme ad una quantità di cellule
organizzate e strutturate capaci di
reagire agli stimoli che fanno mille
miliardi di cellule dentro il nostro
cervello mille miliardi di cellule nel
cervello è una numerosità che supera le
stelle della nostra galassia
anche questo un mistero ancora
largamente inesplorato un mister
inesplorato che non sappiamo come
funzioni ma sappiamo che funziona ci
aiuta a vivere tutti i giorni a
respirare interagire con gli altri a
generare tecnologia ad abituarci alla
tecnologia a sviluppare macchine capaci
di calcolare una numerosità di dati che
straordinariamente più grande della
capacità di organizzazione del nostro
cervello per alcuni aspetti
o forse no il cervello si organizza
collegando cellule tra loro sviluppando
sinapsi le sinapsi sono la rete
biologica alla base del nostro pensiero
abbiamo nel cervello 100 mila miliardi
di sinapsi e una quantità
straordinariamente grande ma questa
quantità così grande non è confrontabile
oggi con
la capacità di calcolo del supercomputer
più grosso che abbiamo generato oggi
abbiamo generato computer capaci di
elaborare milioni di miliardi di
operazioni ogni secondo questo è
l'immagine del sangue taiwo e il
supercomputer cinese più potente al
mondo
questo oggetto creato dal nostro
cervello è capace di elaborare 93
milioni di miliardi di operazioni ogni
secondo stiamo andando verso complessità
che sono apparentemente superiori a
quelle della nostra galassia a quella
del nostro cervello a quelle delle
nostre capacità di collegare le cellule
tra loro ma stiamo vivendo una pagina di
fantascienza e da una pagina di
fantascienza che io vorrei partire in
questa nostra chiacchierata sulla
complessità una pagina che mi ha
insegnato molto
questo è un passaggio del libro di
asimov un genio che nel 1950 scriveva in
ai robot ambientando in una saga che
parla di come l'uomo vivrà a contatto
con i robot la loro vita naturale una
conversazione tra una persona più grande
e una più giovane è la più grande e
chiede al giovane quanti anni hai e il
giovane risponde 32 è la più grande dice
beh allora non ricordi
un giorno il mondo senza robot c'è stato
un tempo in cui l'umanità era sola ad
affrontare l'universo senza un amico ora
creature che l'aiutano creature più
forti dell'uomo più fedeli più utile
assolutamente leali l'umanità non è più
sola
è straordinario evocativo nel 1950 c
proiettava nel ragionamento per cui la
tecnologia quando passa diventa un
oggetto talmente naturale da non
renderci conto della velocità con cui ci
adattiamo io non ho mai compreso la
portata di questo messaggio fino in
fondo
finché un giorno mio figlio passando di
fronte a questo oggetto mi chiede papà
cos'è poi immaginate lo stupore lelli di
mio figlio nel sentirsi raccontare che
un giorno per telefonare bisognava stare
vicini a un muro attaccati ad un oggetto
che non mandava sms che non aveva
whatsapp
perché ci sono tecnologie con cui i
nostri figli sono nati e crescono
tecnologie che oggi in questa stanza
sono nella tasca di molti di voi dentro
questa stanza c'è una capacità di
elaborazione che la nasa non aveva
quando ha mandato sulla luna e il primo
uomo
oggi questi oggetti ci hanno consentito
di amplificare le nostre capacità di
comunicare in questo momento ognuno di
voi avrà un'email che parla con un certo
linguaggio ad un certo tipo di persone
avrà un po su facebook che parla con un
linguaggio diverso ad altri tipi di
persone sono oggetti che hanno
moltiplicato la nostra capacità di
raggiungere le relazioni con gli altri
eppure c'è una cosa di fronte a cui il
cellulare oggi si deve fermare questi
non sono oggetti capaci di svolgere
azioni nel mondo fisico ma allora qual è
la prossima frontiera è inevitabile
avremo bisogno di sviluppare oggetti che
nel mondo fisico sviluppi nazione
avremo bisogno di sviluppare robot ma in
realtà ognuno di voi ha un robot a casa
sì e non sto parlando di stazioni di
lavoro complesse e capaci di svolgere
operazioni articolate ma confinate in
grandi aree industriali oggi sto
parlando di oggetti che sentono
l'ambiente circostante che capiscono
cosa devono fare che prendono delle
azioni e che muovono delle azioni che
capiscono che strada fare se l'impasto
della mia ricetta è adatto se la
temperatura della mia stanza funziona
questi son robot o meglio sono gli
elementi costituenti di quelli che
saranno i robot
io ho la fortuna di aver fatto un lungo
percorso immerso nella ricerca
scientifica circondato da scienziati che
si confrontavano con la complessità che
abbiamo visto e mi farebbe piacere poter
condividere con voi è fatto il pil come
questa ricerca scientifica potrà
arrivare nelle nostre case mestiere
durissimo che ero chiamato a fare potrà
arrivare nelle vostre case e la robotica
per me è un esempio straordinario un
esempio straordinario forse unico di una
tecnologia capace di essere la palestra
il luogo di accoglienza la convergenza
di molti molti diversi modi di
affrontare la scienza questo è il robot
umanoide ai cubs sviluppato
dall'istituto italiano di tecnologia di
genova e adottato
da più di 30 centri di ricerca in giro
per il mondo beh veramente una palestra
dove bisogna progettare giunti capaci di
essere compliant ovvero resistenti
quando ce n'è bisogno cedevoli nel caso
opposto sensori che consentano al robot
di capire dove sta andando elettronica
bisogna sviluppare il firmware software
deliri di alto livello sistemi di
visione bisogna consentirgli di capire
cosa c'è intorno a lui
in questo passaggio il robot non conosce
la palla rossa viene viene mostrata una
gli viene detto in maniera naturale
questa è una palla rossa e lui
acquisisce l'informazione diventa un
pezzo della sua cultura della sua
coscienza
quando poi gli chiederanno indicami la
palla rossa e robot sarà in grado di
guardare un ambiente destrutturato
riconoscere l'oggetto di interesse di
indicarlo e distinguerlo da un oggetto
che magari già conosceva
bisogna creare macchine che comincino ad
apprendere ad acquisire informazioni i
sistemi di elaborazione che gli stiamo
stiamo creando per fare un confronto
sono un po diversi da quello che oggi un
navigatore oggi al vostro navigatore
abbiamo già dato la mappa delle strade e
gli chiediamo di portarci da un punto a
a un punto b bene questi robot quella
mappa la disegneranno da sola dovranno
scegliere in che modo fare le loro
azioni dovranno mettere assieme questi
input e dovranno avere una capacità di
elaborazione che non possono portarsi
dietro è qui che cominciamo a lavorare
con intelligenza e distribuite lavoriamo
in cloud siamo in grado di insegnare
cose nuove a questi robot
sì perché non ci metteremo programmarli
mali mostreremo semplicemente come fare
le cose
ed è così che loro costruiranno un pezzo
alla volta una libreria di conoscenze
che tramite il cloud potranno
condividere condividere tra gruppi di
robot tra popolazioni di robot la
velocità con cui l'esperienza collettiva
di questi robot crescerà e straordinaria
immaginate di avere un amico che a tokyo
fa un sushi straordinario e immaginate
di volergli chiedere che questo lo
insegna al suo robot e che con un click
possa arrivare quando vara robot di casa
vostra che riuscirà a farvi un sushi
straordinario
semplicemente perché lo ha imparato dal
suo collega che sta a tokyo per questa è
la cosa più vicino al teletrasporto che
io riesca ad immaginare
bene sono degli esperimenti degli
esperimenti di sintesi che stanno per
arrivare nelle nostre case e che hanno
un passato molto lontano oggi per far
ragionare un robot in termini di
elaborazione delle informazioni usiamo
delle strutture matematiche che sono
note da 50 anni sono reti neurali in cui
le cellule sono digitali i collegamenti
sono digitali ma la struttura ricorda
molto quello del cervello bene
funzionano perché abbiamo supercomputer
a disposizione che consentono di
elaborare i dati in tempi molto più
brevi di quanto non facessero prima
abbiamo una quantità di dati disponibili
grazie ad internet a questa densità di
collegamenti tra di noi e questo ci
consente di allenare questi cervelli in
maniera preventiva e cosa ce ne faremmo
di tutta questa intelligenza distribuita
beh probabilmente ci aiuteranno a vivere
meglio anzi io ne sono convinto ci
aiuteranno a gestire situazioni in cui
c'è bisogno di una presenza e molte
volte la presenza umana non è sempre
disponibile
non è possibile probabilmente essere lì
in ogni ora del giorno e della notte
così si può delegare delle azioni che
magari per noi sono pesanti routinarie
che loro invece possono fare con un
livello di interazione e di stimolo
straordinario
possiamo immaginare di poter condividere
con loro i nostri gusti dello shopping e
trovarceli in un negozio e magari sapere
che loro sono nostri amici su facebook
sanno già che sto per andare in vacanza
e mi serve quel tipo di tavola da surf e
magari collegarlo con ciò che c'è in
magazzino fare un ordine in maniera da
collegarci con questi sistemi
potremmo trovarla a casa nostra magari
avrò una nonna che ha bisogno di essere
accompagnata durante la giornata mentre
io sono al lavoro avrò dei bambini a cui
bisognerà preparare la colazione la
mattina per lasciare che io mi godo il
buon umore dei ragazzi e non la noia di
dover di fare a preparargli vestiti o
preparargli la colazione è un percorso
che parte da una grandissima complessità
distribuita su neuroscienze su scena
se informatiche sulla capacità di
generare il computer sulla capacità di
collegarli tra loro
bene da questa enorme complessità della
quale noi siamo largamente inconsapevoli
perché ci viviamo in mezzo ogni giorno e
dalla capacità di trasformare questa
complessità in tecnologia per richiamare
l'amico asimov
vi posso dire non ne trarremo un futuro
migliore un futuro che sta arrivando e
che fra poco diventerà il vostro futuro
quotidiano grazie
[Applauso]